a million a million dollars to spend on
the ocean actually 1 billion dollars
hypothetically speaking this was the
question the Economist put two five of
the world's leading thinkers in ocean
conservation billion dollars a billion
dollars doesn't go very far this day
[Music]
for seven decades Sir David Attenborough
has brought the natural world into
people's homes his groundbreaking
television series Blue Planet raise
global awareness of mankind's impact on
the ocean
so how would Sir David spend that 1
billion dollars I would spend a bit of
it on trying to persuade the nations of
the world that these are the property of
humanity as a whole and had to be dealt
with by human beings getting together
and agreeing on a policy to look after
the precious things of the ocean
countries have long disputed how the
oceans should be governed but there is a
framework in place each coastal nation
governs the water that extends 12
nautical miles from its shore known as
its
territorial sea for up to 200 nautical
miles out
coastal nations have their own exclusive
economic zones where they have sovereign
rights to resources like fish oil and
minerals beyond that it's the high seas
a vast expanse of water owned at once by
everyone and no one
a basic law of the sea does exist and a
tangle of overlapping authorities often
with conflicting mandates oversees
particular activities and little
consequence for nations that don't abide
by it
negotiations are underway for a new
treaty to protect the biodiversity of
the high seas but to make it effective
it will need to have more teeth than its
predecessors
so David's 1 billion dollars could be
spent on funding and demonstrating the
value of multinational enforcement
schemes there's any negotiations over
the high seas face a major stumbling
block fishing rights if I have a billion
dollars I will establish Nortec zones
Zephir Kaiser kaya is a conservationist
from Turkey the main problem right now
is the resource management we over
exploited many things as a result of
unsustainable fishing practices over a
third of the world's fish stocks have
collapsed
mr. Kazu kaya's successfully convinced
his government to create 3000 hectares
where fishing isn't allowed otherwise
known as no-take zones this is the most
major spawning and nursery area so
that's why we have to keep this area
safe from all kinds of fishing pressure
no mature professional any kind in the
ten years since mr. Kissel kaya's
no-take zone has been in place marine
biomass has increased by 800% but
there's a problem
less than 1% of the whole ocean surface
is no fishing zone and within this 1%
probably half of 10 is not well enforced
creating no-take zones is one thing
policing them is another putting the
marine protected areas on the paper is
no fishing zone doesn't mean anything
do we have Rangers do have born do we
have people protecting these areas from
any illegal activity illegal unreported
or unregulated fishing accounts for 1 in
every 5 fish taken from the scene and
this is where Suffolk izakaya will spend
his 1 billion dollars technology could
easily help the satellite technology or
high-tech drones which can fly in really
long distances it is the most time
consuming money consuming part of marine
conservation that's where we need this
billion dollar but to convince the
international community to create more
marine protected areas requires evidence
and that means more science so what
would I do with 1 billion dollars a
scientist may be a bit obvious that I
would want to invest it in science we do
have large gaps in our knowledge that
need to be filled dr. Suzanne Lockhart
is a marine biologist with a particular
interest in Coldwater coral it may seem
that we know a lot about the ocean but
it is the tip of the iceberg of what we
need to know in order to keep our ocean
healthy
[Music]
just two years ago dr. Lockhart became
the first person to ever explore the
floor of Antarctica's Weddell Sea
[Music]
Antarctica has some of the densest and
most diverse seabed communities you
could ever see many thought these waters
were too deep and too cold to support
much life but on this expedition her
team uncovered fast coral reefs teeming
with marine life
[ __ ] sea stars we can learn so much
from a thousand-year-old coral colony
dr. Lockhart's research has been used as
the basis for a proposal to create the
world's biggest marine protected area 1
million square miles in the Antarctic
with an extra 1 billion dollars dr.
Lockhart believes scientific research
could help to protect much more of the
ocean there will always be those
countries that block consensus because
they claim a lack of knowledge so if we
can go into those remote areas and
collect evidence then it makes it very
hard for them to dispute the fact that
we need protection the ocean is under
threat as a result of human activity
could one way of protecting it focus on
how people live on land I'd spend a
billion dollar on batteries
Doug McCauley is a professor of marine
biology at the University of California
Santa Barbara I know it's a little bit
strange for a marine biologist to
suggest batteries but indeed that's
precisely where I put my investment
professor McAuley has pioneered the use
of technology in the conservation of
some of the world's most endangered
marine species the challenge for a
marine biologist is that you're doing
all these things and you must do these
things and they matter and yet looming
behind you is this master threat to the
oceans climate change
climate change is causing the ocean to
overheat increasing the level of acidity
and reducing the oxygen content of the
water
so what could batteries do to help us
fight climate change there are
essentially the most important
ingredient in a low-carbon future and
it's because they are the storehouses
for this low-carbon energy that we need
to capture the world relies on
lithium-ion batteries green technology
is being developed around their use but
this type of battery requires minerals
like cobalt which have a controversial
supply chain to meet the growing demand
for batteries mining companies are
turning their attention to the deep sea
there's a lot of uncertainty in the
ocean science community about exactly
what ocean mining would do to ocean
ecosystems but I can tell you the
uncertainty is about how bad mining will
be for our seas not whether it'll be
good batteries are essential to reducing
co2 emissions
professor McAuley wants radical
innovation to invest the 1 billion
dollars in designing powerful
next-generation batteries ones which
won't depend on mining the sea when we
are able to come up with an alternative
to a lithium ion battery well then the
cost of electric vehicles will come
crashing down the faster we can bring
that low-carbon future to us the more
likely it is that we see a reduction in
extinction in the oceans and major
disruptions to ocean health
living in an ocean obsessed household
Doug seven-year-old son Finn has his
thoughts about where he'd spend the
money I'd put an alien dollars you're
gonna fill you in actually billion
dollars to save the fat keep that the
vaquita is a type of porpoise on the
brink of extinction only 10 individuals
still remain in the wild I think you
should just see them and then maybe
you'd save like 30 other species that
needs what kita for the food chain Peter
Thompson is the united nations special
envoy for the ocean I'd take that
billion dollars and I would direct it
into education his mission is to
galvanize the international community to
prioritize ocean conservation there's a
fundamental disconnect between what we
know in ocean science and what Georgia
the population knows when you think of
some things like every second breath of
oxygen you take comes from the ocean and
this should be one of the fundamental
things that we are learning about and in
our daily life the ocean regulates the
planet's climate it provides the main
food source to nearly half the global
population and underpins trillions of
dollars worth of economic activity
worldwide if you give people that
knowledge they're gonna start making the
right decisions and not just individuals
but communities governments and
international bodies have to be supplied
with the right science
there is no single solution to the
multitude of threats facing the ocean
and it will take more than a billion
dollars to drive change as a man-made
disasters what faces us and what we are
having to deal with only through
reshaping the way Humanity lives and
uses the ocean can this vital part of
planet earth be saved and that will take
not just the creativity of individuals
but the collaboration of Nations
people won't care about things that they
don't know about I've never seen and
that your first job is to make ter what
a wonderful world the natural world is
[Music]
if you'd like to find out more about
some of the greatest challenges facing
the ocean and the people trying to solve
them including some of those you've just
seen in this film then please click on
the link opposite for more on the
protective series click the other link
thank you for watching and please
subscribe